こんにちは
食べ物大好き　はじめしゃちょーです
みなさんマック行った時にあのセットとかで頼むと
ポテトをよく食べると思うんですよ
なんかポテトあんま好きじゃなくて
いつもはバーガーとなんか飲み物とかって頼むんですよ
なぁ所沢
所沢:そうだね
というわけでマックのポテトＬサイズがあると思うんですけども
Ｌサイズはえー170g入っています
こちらですね　これが170g
340g
510g
ハッ
ハッハッハッハッハッハッハ
私は気づいてしまった
ポテトってなんか油が多そうに見えると思うんですよ
みなさん　多分そう思っている人が多いと思います
でもそんなことはなくて
ポテトは
畑から採れる野菜の一種
ここにポテトＬ170gが6個
のポテトがあります
で、カロリーがえっと
あっ…
で、僕思ったんですよ
あの普段ハンバーガー食べているから
お腹が膨らむようにみえると思うんですけども
実際ポテトって
あるとｗ思うんですよｗ
いやマジで
所詮はだって野菜ですからね
なんできっと今お腹が空いている僕だと
お腹が膨れないんで
もう食べても食べても止まんないんで
もう感覚が麻痺して
あっさり3000kcal食えるんじゃねぇーかなーと思いまして
今回はポテト1Kg食べてみようと思います
1人でな！！
(パンッ)いただきます
いやマジで思ったより多く見えないんだが
もっとこういうのだと思ってたんすけど
1キロが割とこじんまりしててなんか余裕そうっすねー
じゃあもう、ちょっとしなってきてるんですぐ食べようと思います
いただきます
うん
うまい　いや僕どっちかっていうとしなしなポテトも方が好きなんすよね
うん、なんかじゃがいも感がちゃんとあります
うまっ
え、ほんとに止まんねーよこれうまっ
でもなぁ…
わざわざ食べようとも思わないんすよね
やばいもう無理
かもしんないなぁ
うわぁ待って本当に多いなぁ
しなってるからなんかちょっとしたってなってるんすけど
多分揚げたてだったらほんと
こういうサイズでしたね
これやばい過去最強にキツイかもしれん
ちょっとケチャップ使います
味変がねぇ1番多分効果的なんでしょうね
同じ味を食ってると飽きてしまいますんで
これでちょっと味を
変わんねぇな根本的な部分は
あ、でも多少マシになるんで
ケチャップでもうちょっと食べてみます
マジやばい
マジやばいこれ
ほんとやばい
(鼻歌〜)
うぅ
これ大変だ
トントントントントントン
これすごいマジで
人じゃねぇーよ
大変だぁ〜
すいません
でも…
全部食べたいんで
いでよ召喚獣
ハッハッハッ　ハイッ
妖怪エロカッパことたなっち:やばいマジでやばい
たなっち:いや元の量をみてないからわかんないんすけど
はじめ:元がこんぐらい
たなっち:あぁえ、じゃあもう結構頑張ったんすね
はじめ:いやマジで食った
たなっち:すげー
はじめ:2人でも、でも1キロ食ったってすごいから
たなっち:うん
たなっち:俺いけると思ってました
はじめ:そとはかとねえものがあるこいつは
はじめ:いや食べます食べます
はじめ:ブッ(吐血)
はじめ:あとは…
はじめ:任せた
はじめ:見て
はじめ:カンブリア紀にいた
たなっち:ｗｗｗ顔
たなっち:イケメンYouTuberがする顔じゃねーもん
はじめ:待ってやばいやばい油がすごい
はじめ:そうだったｗ
たなっち:油ですよあれ
たなっち；ねぇポテトサラダだもんガチ、ガチで
たなっち:マジでポテトサラダ　ウェ
はじめ:よっしゃー
はじめ:う”ぅ”ーーーーーー
はじめ:う”ーー結構食ったよねでも
たなっち:結構食った　下手したら1人でいけた
はじめ:これ元の量言っていい？
たなっち:うん
はじめ:こんぐらいなんだ
たなっち:え？こんくらいのこんくらいを残したんじゃなくて？
はじめ:こんくらいのこんぐらいを残した
たなっち:ねぇ
【はじめしゃちょーエンディング】